talking of unlikely encounters because
this was all in the papers because your
your little well just because what we
read in our papers I got yeah I got a
car so this was the was it you think
rugged right it was J with James Blunt
is James Blunt China get his pop career
back the papers I don't know there
wasn't a lot of people there that night
so you can say allegedly what happened
okay allegedly one of the princesses
Eugenia Beatrice one of them and James
Blunt and Ed Sheeran we're in a room was
a million a palace James blood allegedly
wanted to be knighted is that a
euphemism and so one of the princesses
found a handy sword well item did you
not read this in the papers I didn't
know James Blunt was involved up to that
point anyway there was a bit of
swordplay and Ed sure and got caught the
face is that right do you know what I I
have no idea how that story came out I
have no idea cuz it's like it was so
tight it was and like for like two weeks
afterwards I had this huge gash on my
face and people would be like Oh what
happened you'd be like ah I fell
[Applause]
[Music]